They've got it. Cool. Amazing. So,
welcome everyone. I'm Vincent. Uh, what
do I do? I'm one of the core maintainers
at OpenClaw, working with Peter. And as
you've heard before, I have a day job as
well. Same as Peter. he has a day job at
OpenAI. Um, but you know, it's an open
source project. Amazing things have been
happening. I'm going to talk about what
I call dark factories and how open claw
ships faster than you can read the diff.
Um, this meme is absolutely hilarious.
So, I think Peter posted this a week or
two ago. I wake up, there's a new
technological advancement. I wake up.
It's this this joke that we're shipping
at insane speed and the velocity is just
absolutely phenomenal. And some of you
might think, oh, this is some luck or
we're just like raal flipping to the
max. Um, I think there's actual
engineering work here and I'm going to
talk about that. Now, as I mentioned,
I'm Vincent. I'm your friendly clanker.
Uh, this is me using VR goggles back in
2013. So, despite my accent that sounds
somewhat Australian, I was born and
raised in East London, not far from
here. I actually went to to college just
down the road in Westminster. And, yeah,
at some point decided to live in
Australia. my accent changed. But I used
to love technology. I used to love being
at the edge of technology. And this was
like one of the first few sort of early
um VR goggles that came out. Came in
this big box with a big warning sign on
it saying, "Hey, use for 5 minutes at a
time." Cuz it didn't have like the
anti-motion sickness built into it. And
the funny thing with this one here was
that I didn't use it for 5 minutes. I
used it for 3 hours. And I played Team
Fortress 2, had an absolute blast. And
then I vomited for three hours after
that cuz my vision turned into B vision.
Um the what I'm trying to say here is
that like anything on the edge is going
to be janky. It's going to be horri
horrific. It's going to be uh uncharted
territory. And working on openclaw and
being part of the team that ships
probably you know an insane velocity of
commits to a point where I get ray
limited by GitHub on an hourly basis uh
is an interesting experience. And this
experience Britain's gone through
before. Um we had the industrial
revolution when mills and cotton were
being produced at extreme amounts of
volume. And there's a lot of history
here around production and
productionization at scale uh in the UK
and in Europe. And I feel like we're
going through this moment again. Uh
we're going through this moment of how
do we build at scale? And the ways we
used to work before just don't work
anymore. And
it's kind of strange because in my day
job I kind of work in the space of evals
which everything is sort of structured
and there's telemetry and it has to be
all perfect and I work on a project
where I'm I have this blind faith in the
harness and it's this kind of two walls
but they're starting to come together.
We used to have hand looms in cottages
uh centralized mills everywhere. uh
craftsmen were the factory workers, but
the bottleneck was the weaver's hands.
We're now switching to a world where
engineers writing code and editors not
so much. Uh swarms across repos,
uh engineers are becoming factory
managers, which I'm going to talk to.
And the bottleneck becomes taste, you
know, that lovely word Italian mother's
hands. Yes.
So in in context, like what does this
mean? Like are you talking absolute
nonsense? the people building things at
absolute scale. they are. What happened
was um very similar to the chat chutt
era where everyone denied it at scale
that they were using chatt everyone was
in this absolute fear-mongering sort of
world but what the reality was that
everyone was using it everyone in secret
was just like oh my god what's going on
I need to talk to it and the same thing
is happening with this autonomous agents
at scale some organizations have openly
come out with it so for example
anthropic uh with their recent work they
did on building a new C compiler
Uh we had Spotify saying they they're no
longer writing code by hand supposedly.
Um Steve Jger, which I absolutely love,
uh saying he pushes about 50 PRs a day,
total solo. He calls himself a vibe
maintainer. I can kind of relate to
that. And Open Core, where we're pushing
at the peak, we were doing 800 commits a
day. And realistically, like there's
about 10 to 15 core maintainers, all
with day jobs. It's kind of astronomical
in terms of scale.
And for me, this was March 15. Um, what
was that like two or three weeks ago
where I hit close to 3,000 commits per
day. And if you actually took look, my
commits actually stop when I go to
sleep. So, if you if you want to see
when I go to sleep and when I wake up
and how many hours of sleep I have, you
can just take a look at my commit
history. Yeah, it's astronomical. But
the thing is this is going to become the
norm everywhere else. Like this is this
is like a me telling you you need to
wake up that you know this scale of
velocity is going to be normal and
trying to review PRs and go through all
this nonsense may not work but somewhere
in the mix is engineering there is a
form of engineering that's going to
happen so we did commit maxing you know
let's just go there smash as many
commits as we can and this reminds me of
Ralph looping right this like this this
this this guy where you're like hey I'm
just going to like give you a task I'm
going to burn tokens for like 8 to nine
hours and you're waiting, you know, uh
you're waiting, you're hoping something
happens, maybe something happens, I
don't know. Um but what if we had a bit
more of an opinionated uh approach to
this? Um what if we call it bart
looping? I don't know. Uh one of the
other maintainers gave me this idea.
Maybe we'll coin it. Do we do we need
more than just tokens? Uh what does that
reward mechanism look like? How do we
get a bit more opinionated? Yes, let's
run loops, but let's be a bit more smart
about how we do this.
So, um, right about the time you saw
those 3,000 commits, uh, this was the
day before I was at NVIDIA with Peter,
and the gentleman you see on the left is
is one of the other, uh, Nvidia
gentlemen, and they were like, "Hey,
we're building Nemo Claw." I'm like,
"What? What's going on?" And, uh, let's
help you build it. And I was in the
room. I was like, "I can't work on a
laptop for like hours on end. Can you
bring me a screen?" They bought me a
screen. Um, Peter didn't have a screen,
so that's his laptop on the left. He
asked for a screen, so they gave him an
even bigger screen than mine because,
you know, why not? And we just got to
work. So, he's running about maybe 15
codec sessions, and he's got his Mac
Studio Home, his VPN into I'm running
another like 10 or 15. And between
collectively between us, we're probably
running with sub agents included, maybe
up to 60, 70 agents. Um, but on the
foreground, maybe 15 uh swim lanes if
you want to call it that. And we're just
just going for it. Funny thing is we're
working on Nemo claw one side but one
maintainer decided I'm going to move
some stuff around. I'm going to move a
couple of folders around and that was
moving entire channels. So like all our
conversations with like MS Teams and
Slack ended up moving to another
location in the codebase
and we were like oh my goodness we're
going to have to change stuff. Um and I
found a really nice uh place to put my
drink as well. The Nvidia people don't
like this. So what ended up happening is
what we call the great refactor. Um
essentially where we were like hey we
have lots of people raising PRs and what
they actually want is to build features.
The thing is we don't want to give
everyone every single feature that they
want in which case it becomes bloat. Uh
you heard Peter say earlier on the
challenge becomes who do I say no to?
It's not about saying yes. In a world
where tokens are cheap I can just say
yes to absolutely everyone and merge
everything in. But that's going to turn
this codebase into an absolute fire
dump. So the vision was actually we need
to cut this codebase down. We need to we
need to rip it into pieces and a plug-in
architecture somewhat made sense.
Imagine if you're OpenAI or Mistral or
Anthropic, what if you own that piece of
the provider code and it was handed to
you and it was separate from everything
else. So this code change that occurred
was like a catalyst for us. It was 2 in
the morning. We're tired. We thought why
not refactor the entire codebase? Sounds
like a splendid idea. So, 2,700 commits
later, uh, close to a million lines of
code change, uh, touching 82% of the
core codebase, plugins were launched.
Um, the night before, I think it was
like 1:00 in the morning, I'm trying to
go to sleep and the tests are not
passing and I was like, was Icarus and
did I fly too close to the sun? Um, as
we like to call it, did I did I vibe too
hard? I actually generally thought I
vibe too hard. But as a team, we managed
we managed to bring this codebase back
together again. But the saving grace was
these awful sort of unit tests that AI
code loves to generate that actually
ended up overfitting on our code. So
when we completely ripped everything
out, we still had these tests that were
like extremely overfitting and as long
as they would go green, we knew we were
kind somewhat close.
Um, so how did we do this? you know um
in my case I call it my factory it's
many codec sessions everyone asks me
like what's this magic source like how
how do you do this what's this crazy
insane thing like how are you guys
building this very simple I have swim
lanes um it could be five it could be 10
it could be 20 but traditionally they
kind of cut themselves up into different
pieces so like if I does this work the
laser you can't really see it but
imagine you're a factory manager and you
have a production line blow essentially
you might have a case where you have uh
let's just say CI to one side you might
have features in one side you might have
bugs in another so when I'm refactoring
and doing stuff um right now the
codebase is quite stable I want to
refactor some tests well that might be
swim lanes one and two I don't need to
really babysit them too much I just tell
them take your time make sure the tests
pass just commit just just push them
through whereas with three and four I
might be looking at specific features
and issues around say Docker or um one
of our messaging channel channels in
which case I'm having a conversation
with those agents they're going off
investigating doing the work coming back
and then maybe five is actually um
looking at new P 0 and P1's um that
might be using other data might be using
GitHub uh we have agents that run inside
of a Discord channel. So when we do a
release, we might be like, hey, what's
happened in the last two hours that I
need to be paying attention to and this
will scale up and down. But what ends up
becoming quite interesting is tokens are
no longer the problem. Um, depends who
you ask. What really ends up becoming
the problem is just raw compute and my
brain space in order to sort of keep an
eye on all of these sessions. So in
harness, we trust what ends up happening
is I don't have this really insanely
complicated process. The one thing I
have complicated in my life is adopting
git work trees and I kind of wish I
hadn't. The only reason why I say this
is when you're running an extremely
heavy test harness, it ended up
completely nuking my machine cuz I ended
up running like every PR attach ends up
becoming a new git work tree. I end up
with like some close to like 70 or 80
active git work trees in any given day
on my machine and that's kind of hell.
Um, so I had to actually build some like
magic source around my my codec session.
So my codeex is aware of get work trees
if I hit the escape key it crashes it
will selfheal self-reover get you know
sparse stuff but realistically I should
have adopted what Peter and other people
do is just like clone the repo 10 times
and point 10 different you know codec
sessions to each one but the trick here
is that like I haven't done any magical
source I don't use plan mode or spec
mode I have a conversation with the
agent and we work through it and we find
a way to make it work
so realistically it looks a little bit
like this from the matrix Um, and people
go, "Oh, Vincent, like, how do you know
it's kind of working?" And this is going
to sound somewhat a little bit lunatic.
It it if if anyone's watched The Matrix
and seen the scene where Neo goes over,
he's like, "How do you know? How do you
read the text?" And the guy's like, "Oh,
you know, I've been doing this for a
while, so I can see like woman in red
dress or guy walking dog." And you start
to have this like relationship where you
can feel the reasoning tokens. I know it
sounds somewhat ludicrous, but there's
times where I'm looking at the swim lane
and I'm like, "This sounds off. It
doesn't sound off because of what it's
doing. It sounds off because of how it's
explaining itself to me. It's waffling.
It's not making sense. It doesn't seem
to know what it's doing." And this feels
a lot like how I would manage people.
Um, if I had someone working for me and
they started downright bullshitting, I'd
be like, "Wait a minute, what's going
on?" So in these cases, I might just
nuke the session and go, you know, I'm
not going to deal with this section of
code. I'm going to leave that to another
maintainer or I might come back to it
four or five days later. But that
experience feels very much like
intuitive and building that intuition
I've been able to get to because of the
sheer volume of token maxing I've had to
go through in the previous year.
So there is engineering work. Uh I call
this the agent development environment.
Um essentially the process goes I have
skills I call it skills similar to dot
um dot files both of my dot skills and
dot files is available on GitHub it's
all open source go for it some of my
skills are private but there's skills in
there for like writing technical
documentation for example um that I've
co-created with other um developer
experience and other engineers in the
market um you can use a skills gym
something like a ger which I'm also a
contributor to and or you could just
Hey, go codeex. I've been using this
skill in my last uh two weeks. Go
through the codec sessions, read the
logs, make improvements to the skill. Um
I would then take that skill and deploy
that into my openclaw or take that into
my know personal environment and I'll
use something like versel skills.sh as
like a mechanism to loop this. I've
added some other testing and other
elements on top of this, but there's a
process to how I manage and maintain my
skills as an engineer.
The way we manage PRs has some level of
engineering work to it. Um there's this
kind of running joke that every
maintainer that joins the project
decides to try and tackle like oh my god
we have 6,000 PRs. How are we going to
solve it? I'm going to cluster
everything and like figure this out. So
>> how many
>> there you go. There you go. Honor. Thank
you very much. So this was my flavor of
like trying to solve this. This is like
a semantic graphing uh vector embedding
on the entire GitHub stuff. This is one
PR has 73 ed uh 106 edges. What ends up
happening is that everyone else has the
same problem. So they decide to to send
their flavor of the PR issue becomes
utter noise. So there is even process
around like how we even consume what
we're going to work on. We might not
call it a road map, but we have a way of
kind of dduplicating and seeing what's
out there. This might be a signal for me
to say, okay, if there's enough pressure
coming on one issue, it must be big
enough that all these other clankers
decided it's a big problem. Maybe I
should go and address it. There is evals
surprisingly. Um after all this
refactoring work, we decided to make a
fake Slack of sorts with both synthetic
models and real models so we can run
evaluation loops to check that each of
the providers and the channels work.
And this question was asked of me
recently. How do you manage 10 plus
agents? And this is something that
you're thinking. I asked them back, how
do you manage 10 plus staff? And they
had no answer for me. I'd worked in
large organizations like airlines and
other places like that managing large AI
teams. I had experience managing up to
30 40 people plus. So for me it was not
like a a new paradigm. But I think for
engineers and people working with these
coding agents at scale, it's the soft
skills that matter. It's how do you ask
your agent what's going on? How do you
know when they're not bullshitting you?
And how do you run that factory? So it's
no longer about the model or the agent.
It's about the process. Uh 2025 was
about token maxing. 2026 is about not
wasting them. It's about token
efficiency. It's about agent in the
loop. Thank you.